It's not my fault that she was able to hold a story together.
It's not my fault that Turkey Tom apparently did her so bad that
she lost her mind and wanted to try and ruin him. But I did my
due diligence in proving that she was in a relationship with
him. Had been at his house, had pictures of her there like they
both did.
>> Okay, we've got a couple major things. We've got the
null interview. How do I set this up? So, we had the turkey response
a couple days ago. If you guys remember, null, the person who
administers owns Kiwi Farms, interviewed the two women who were
accusing Turkey Tom, right? He did a very strange interview where
he's basically just trying to extract maximum embarrassing information
on Turkey Tom, right? He wasn't really looking to establish the
actual allegations. He wasn't looking to give them weight or
figure out if they should have weight given to them. He was essentially
just trying to extract
uh embarrassment, maximum reputational damage, which now looks
very silly because if you've been following along at all, these
people kind of got totally goofed on, right? Like I do believe
Clorox Katy is now totally turned on the other girl who's making
accusations,
right?
I do believe so. By the way, null cannot get mad at the big white
comments because null is the guy who when when rubber meets the
road, null had to know how big is Tom's.
Could you just tell me for the record like how big is Tom's really?
He's the one who asked the question. He has to deal with the
fact that now Tom put that in his response
multiple times. Okay, he can't complain about it. No, you're
the one who asked. You're the one who had to know. You wanted
to know this. All right. Some say
some say that null,
this is actually Null's favorite response, the the one he wanted
most. Okay. Is that he just wanted to know this whole time how
big Turkey Tom's is? And Turkey Tom finally let him know. Yeah,
it's huge, bro. It's huge. What if it's red and looks like a
turkey neck and that's why he's called Turkey Tom? >> 19th.
[snorts] 5 days after two users joined the Kiwi Farms to accuse
Turkey Tom of misconduct, they reached out to me and asked me
to do an interview with them, which I did. Uh, by all accounts
at the time, uh, my interview was extraordinarily professional
and, uh, did a very good job.
I kind of thought that question was super weird. the question
where you sort of dropped all pretense of professionalism and
just asked how big his was. I kind of felt like that was odd
to tell you the truth >> of uh handling. >> I thought
it was Dude, no way. Hold on. I have to maybe Hold on. Maybe
I'm uh Maybe I'm forgetting. >> This is what you >> Maybe
I'm forgetting. Maybe I don't get
>> How big was this? >> Oh my god. >> Bro,
like I'm sorry. By all accounts, >> uh, by all accounts,
at the time, uh, my interview was extraordinarily
>> I'm I'm just guessing that literally nobody said that.
Extraordinarily professional. And I don't want I don't want to
like fight with Null. I know that that he's got, you know, he
is the guy who controls Kiwi Farms. I don't want to fight with
him. But I'm just like, dude, you got to be you got to be real
about this. You don't get to say you don't get to you had that
intrusive thought. You let it out in the moment. You don't get
to say afterwards that it was extraordinarily professional. Okay,
I'm sorry. You just don't get to you don't get to do it. You
got to you get to either ask how big his was or you get to say
it was a professional interview. You cannot do both.
>> And uh did a very good job of
uh handling a sensitive topic. Um before I interviewed them,
before I allowed them on the forum, I uh >> by the way,
I don't think he did a particularly good job of handling a sensitive
topic. I do think there were times where he could have asked
things like, "Do you have more contemporaneous evidence? Do you
have like anything else here?" He could have gotten a very good
idea speaking to both of them in a real-time environment of precisely
what they knew, what they could provide. I think he became like
an advocate in a way that he wasn't just somebody dispassionately
analyzing the information. He became like an advocate, right?
Because either he didn't ask questions that were obvious to a
lot of people like, "Hey, do you have more contemporaneous messages?
Could we see some more substantiation of some of these allegations?"
either he didn't ask those questions because he knew that they
didn't have them or he'd already asked. In which case, you're
still platforming all of this knowing that there is no more like
elaboration, right? Or you just didn't think to ask those questions.
One of the two. >> I vetted that they had met Turkey Tom
and they had had a relationship with Turkey Tom. Uh which as
far as I am concerned is all the vetting that I need to do. I
correctly evaluated that they had been in a romantic entanglement
with this person and they had things that they wanted to say
and I let them say it. Uh, as far as I am, >> the dumb
[__] isn't taking our [__] posting seriously,
is he?
>> Um, even now that is my only job. >> Uh, I vetted
the bare minimum and I let them say what they had to say.
Uh, as it turns out, one of them uh lied about a significant
amount of information and that put everything that she said into
doubt and uh vicariously made me look bad because she lied. >> Um,
so >> in the interest of fairness, I do apologize if my
>> uh Josh Coping
platform was misappropriated and used to spread lies. Um, Rowan
definitely lied. Uh, and in the process harmed herself, uh, harmed
Turkey Tom, harmed me, harmed the Kiwi Farms, uh, and also harmed
other people who would want to share stories about people, uh,
who had abused them for real. Um, both if it was Turkey or just
general people cuz now, uh, if someone else comes out and says
that this YouTuber was violent,
>> I don't believe this. I think this is what people say
when they took something and they gave more weight to it than
it deserved. I think people say, "Oh, well, you hurt other victims."
It's like I I'm sorry if somebody makes up like allegations.
I don't look at the next person who accuses someone of rape and
go, "I think you're lying cuz the last person made something
up." That's you could say maybe an abstract that could do that
in like aggregate over everybody on the planet or something.
But if you think that, if you are more likely to go, well, I
don't believe this person because somebody else lied, you're
you should just have a good way of analyzing this information
of trying to take it in and see like what's what's true, what's
false, what's unknown, what's known, and you just sort through
it, right? There's I don't know. I I feel like this is something
you say when you're mad that you got lied to, and you want to
you want to make that person feel as bad as possible. >> Towards
me, people will just say, "Well, look at what happened with Turkey
Tom." Um, and I'll remind you because I was accused of trying
to attack Turkey Tom and being unfair towards him, I am one of
the few people who actually defended him before this happened.
Um, I was accused of shielding him from fallout with Kai because
I didn't understand what was going on and I didn't trust that
certain pictures were real or not. >> Is this the chest
carving picture or >> the one where he allegedly carved
her name into his chest and [laughter] that got shared around?
And I was also accused of guarding him because uh after our discussion,
>> by the way, my laughing at that is not to say that that
picture is real. I actually don't know. I've seen people like
reference that picture existing. I've heard some people say it's
fake. It's obviously fake. I've heard other people say, "No,
it it like is real." I do think we now know, unfortunately, this
literally just Tom's private business. But whether or not that
was by carving the name into the chest or what, who knows? He
said something to the effect of her prostate referring to Caffles.
And I made the statement and I made repeatedly that I understand
he's just protecting his cash flow on YouTube. I understand what
he's doing. Um I don't really hold that against him. And I for
that too. And then when I facilitate people having a discussion,
um I'm called out for being
um
trying to bring him down, which does not make sense. So,
I want to I want to have a little reality check because Rowan
lied. Uh,
there's a rot here and I think that it is only fair that we address
that together. Uh first of all after
the uh statements were made both Nick Doro and Audi RFC who are
personal friends of Tom were very like >> I think there's
nothing uh weaker or gayer than than intentionally mispronouncing
somebody's name over and over unless it's in service of a joke.
If you're mispronouncing it as in like you pretend you don't
understand it. Um I think that's like a weak that's just a weak
person thing to do. If you have like a joke, okay, like more
Pegasi
RFC repeatedly, when you know that that's not what it is, when
you've watched multiple things that say his name correctly, I
just think it's pretty obvious you don't like this person and
so you're going to say it incorrectly intentionally cuz you are
just like kind of weakwilled touch in talking about the subject.
And Nicholas Dioro actually gave out an explanation as to why
uh immediately after Rowan started talking about Turkey Tom on
the Kiwi farms. Uh they secluded themselves into a private
Pisco Pisco. I mean that's referring to the part right again
in service of a
I'm saying if you like pretend so when you when you mispronounce
somebody's name that's not like um going towards a joke intentionally.
It's like you trying to say, "I don't know who this person is."
That's what you're trying to do. If you're trying to make like
a If you're making a joke, if you think it's funny,
no, I have no problem with this. That's again the whole point.
Also different with my name versus anybody else's server without
saying that that's what they were doing. Um, there was a video
that I shared of Audi RFC
and I had never watched an Audi video before, but what really
got me is that he kept looking down to smirking to himself. And
I kept thinking that looks a lot like duper's delight. That looks
a lot like uh somebody who thinks they're getting away with lying.
And as it turns out, I should have said,
>> because it's exactly what that was. He knew more than
he was letting on and he was extremely smug and self-satisfied
because uh he was lying to people and getting away with it. Um
but that has been kind of pushed to the waist. >> What
did what did Auggie lie about? >> Because Rowan lied.
Um the video itself was also composed and written by a uh professional
PR team and I can prove this because of how it's structured.
There's a
The Turkey Tom's video is written by a professional PR team and
I can prove this because of how it's structured.
Wait, that's not proving it. That's like you're making an argument.
That's not even remotely proving it.
>> Effectively three parts to this video. The video opens
with a strong >> which I'm not even saying it couldn't
be written by a professional PR team, but why would you say I
can prove that? Because of how it's structured. If you're saying
I'm I'm going to prove that, it's like you should prove it. You
should you should have some you should have more than just like
some evidence that leans in that direction. Anyway, one second.
>> Written by a uh professional PR team. And I can prove
this because of how it's structured. There's effectively three
parts to this video. The video opens with a strong uh indication
that Rowan lied because she did lie. He proves that she lies
about certain things.
Then it closes uh with an emotional chor. It's a voicemail where
uh Rowan basically says to him that she is going to try and ruin
his career because she's angry with him. Uh which is really bad
for somebody who just made a bunch of accusations
two weeks prior to have said on on record. Uh in the middle of
it is just muckthrowing to try and um muddy the waters enough
where nothing else is critically evaluated. So, I'm going to
go through uh kind of a list of everything said, and then once
I am done going through this list, uh I'm going to round this
out with a a final thought. And uh if people want to be mad at
me. >> All right, hold on. Hold on. Okay, so I don't think
for one thing, I don't think that at all proves that this is
written by a professional PR team. I think that's kind of silly
personally,
right? I don't think that remotely proves that this is written
by a professional PR team. It's very, very goofy.
Uh, the commentary guy that does scripts apparently had a PR
team. He had a PR team. I don't even know what that means. Don't
know who that is.
Um,
in any case,
he's like describing this. I would say the reason that this works
or people discount everything is because in some of the most
substantive ways
they were like Rowan was shown to be lying, right? Like it wasn't
that she was just lying a little bit. She was lying like very
very very
obviously majorly on the most substantive things.
That's the problem. And she made a threat about leaking everything
to ruin his reputation after at the end of the relationship and
then she basically followed through on that threat, right? Like
it's not it's not some little weird thing. No, it wouldn't be
bad if he used his PR team. I just I would assume that when you
say I can prove this usually means something. He's like, "I believe
that." He should have said, "I believe this because XYZ." That's
all >> me. They can be mad at me, but I'm not going to
um pretend that
everything is kosher and copathetic cuz it's not. So, let's start
off with what he addressed.
first of all, uh, he proved beyond a shadow of a doubt and Rowan
has
that,
uh, she knew who he was before they matched on Tinder. This is
a catastrophic
foundational lie. Um, and it ruins everything else she has to
say and makes her look uh completely malicious. Uh, she knew
who he was. She had messaged him before on Twitter. Uh, she is
like a micro niche e- celeb like in Discord servers or whatever,
but she knew who he was.
Uh she said that Turkey Tom engaged in non-consent
non-consensual
violent actions against her. Uh which is partially true. Uh they
had rough but she apparently encouraged it in private. Turkey
Tom has logs of it. She admits this is true. Uh he addressed
uh covering her mouth during and giving her bruises on her face.
Uh this was also consensual.
Um
she had accused him of encouraging an eating disorder which uh
he proved was a lie. [snorts] Uh he addressed age play
kind of
duplicitously. Uh he used a picture of a bedroom that had a Lolita
poster on it. Rowan says that this was not her room. This was
her friend's room. Uh but Turkey Tom said that this was her room
and passed it off as such.
I mean, and it should have been obvious to Tom from that thing
that it wasn't her room. Like, even the messages he showed on
his stream, very obviously not her her room at all. >> Um,
he also denied engaging in age play with Ellie, who is a cosplayer
on Instagram. Um, he was having an affair on Instagram with this
girl who is an age player who is into
uh but he on the treadmill. Okay, you guys are mean. What the
[__] He says that he did not engage in age play with
her.
uh he blamed uh her bleeding from on birth control. She denies
that this is true. And uh very
um
importantly, I think this is at the very very end.
There's a um audio recording. I think it's at the very end. Uh
no, I guess not. Where uh she basically says that she's going
to try to ruin him, which [__] up everything that
she has to say. Uh now the other things that he addressed is
that he flexes in the mirror while having like Patrick Batesman
and he says the words big white in this I think 100 act of many
many men uh gushing about BWC in a Kiwi Farms thread praising
his worshiping his
uh talking about how much they love his and how big his is which
is
Not really.
>> yeah, not really.
>> How big was this?
>> Oh my god.
>> Wow. Seems like the kiwi doesn't fall far from the tree.
>> Extremely bizarre thing. And the partial >> I
wonder if I wonder if somebody centered the conversation around.
I wonder if there's somebody who could have interviewed these
women and centered the conversation around >> address uh
first of all he addressed that he uh had consensual recordings
of with uh Rowan. However, he never addressed having recordings
of Katie. Katie accused of accused him of recording her and he
never actually touched on that. uh he only touched on uh Rowan
because Rowan had talked about it and talked about the meta glasses
um which implied that there was at least some consent sometimes.
Uh he addressed the blackmail folder. He has a folder on his
desktop called just in case where he keeps dirt on all of his
exes such as the dirt that was used in this video. Um he says
that he would never blackmail somebody but never denies the folder.
So, the folder exists, and we know it exists because Kai referenced
it in her letter, uh, which did appear to be forced, at least
to me. By the way, I didn't mention this, but,
uh, Kai has messaged me on Twitter and, uh, we exchanged maybe
>> Oh. H,
that's interesting. >> Two, 20 messages over about 3 hours
of conversation.
uh because she took approximately 45 minutes for her to reply
to anything that I said at the end of that conversation. I had
no idea what she was trying to say. I have no idea why she reached
out to me. I cannot discern what her thesis was. She just randomly
messaged me [snorts] and tried to tell me some stuff. I think
the the gist of it was that Turkey Tom definitely wasn't blackmailing
her in any way. No idea what she was trying to say. Um completely
insane.
He partially addressed >> say Ellie who as I mentioned
was a age player. Uh he never denies cheating on Rowan with Ellie.
Uh he never denies the scheme through Ellie. He only denies that
he ever engaged in age play fetish role play with Ellie.
Um and the only other thing that he addresses in regards to body
count.
>> Wait. So he doesn't >> never denies cheating on
Rowan with Ellie. Uh, he never denies the scheme through Ellie.
He >> Wait, was there even an allegation that he cheated
with the Ellie person? Wait, I don't think there was an allegation
that he cheated on Rowan with Ellie. Was there? I think she suspected
cheating cuz he was talking to these women. But I thought he
hung out with Ellie way before
those two got together. Before the Rowan girl and Turkey Tom
got together. I thought it was like or way earlier that they
sorry that they hung out.
I never got the impression that she was saying that Rowan was
saying that he cheated with her. I think it was like the indication
that she was cheating or that he was cheating rather because
he kept talking to this woman. So she got >> Only denies
that he ever engaged in age play fetish roleplay with >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. The the couple pictures, right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
So yeah. So she was being he was being blackmailed by somebody
who apparently allegedly hacked the Ellie girl.
>> Um, and the only other thing that he addresses in regards
to body count is that um, Rowan supposedly also lied about her
body count, but he never talks about how he's having sex with
random women about one per month. Um, which is, I think, alarming.
on the other hand,
there's a list of things that I have organized
as being not addressed at all. In a 40-minute long video, Turkey
Tom manages not to say anything about any of these issues. Let's
go down the list. He does not address his dysfunction or addiction.
He doesn't address that he could not ejaculate during He could
not address that he only finished in pain. He doesn't address
>> well I think
so he could say all of this but none of these things are like
criminal or cancelellable
and so obviously the obvious answer here is Tom's not going to
address anything
that is just innuendo about his personal life or innuendo about
him that's like in this just intrigue about him right he's never
going to he's never going to address something that he doesn't
actually have to address
hey you said something about me I'm never going to talk about
that because I have no interest in talking about that, right?
So, obviously, you know, if I say if I say Tom's like a totally
a total degenerate who can't come without a girl sticking her
finger in his ass, then Tom's not going to actually answer that
except girls calling him daddy. No, no, no, no. Sonic, no. Wrong.
Because he talks about that because he's trying to dispel the
age play thing. So, he's giving a small concession on the age
play lines on those lines to make it seem more believable. That's
not that's not uncalculated just like divulging personal information.
There's an allegation that his friends have deemed substantial
that he has to respond to and so he's giving that as a small
concession there so that it sounds better. Right.
Yeah. That's that's all it is. It's not him if if he didn't feel
like he had to give that concession away to like sort of make
this thing go away in general. I don't think he ever would have
done that. for all the other stuff. I like anything about him
having ED, anything about him, you know, having to watch videos
or something to come. All of that stuff, he's never going to
talk about that. He just recorded videos immediately after, which
both women confirmed. He doesn't address that he has hourlong
beaning sections where he can't finish because uh he has death
grip. He doesn't address his drug use. He doesn't address the
fact that he does. He doesn't address the fact that he's done
nitrous or whippets. He doesn't address the fact that he took
Kai's Adderall. Uh he doesn't address the fact that Kai was his
obsession. He doesn't address the fact that he told both women
that they look like Kai. He doesn't address the >> Dude,
this is giving this list is actually winding this guy super hard
is kind of >> the fact that he bought Monster. >> The
music is being undercut by the fact that this dude's winded for
going through like an eight item list at this >> Uh high
things that Kai like for his other girls. He doesn't address
the fact that he took out aggressions on Sacramento
uh and and Katie because he was angry at Kai. He never addresses
the night voicemails or any other consensual non-consentual adjacent
languages. He never addresses the fact that he told both women
that they look like little girls. He never addresses the fact
that he booked one-way flights only. He never addresses the fact
that he made Katie sit silently during his streams. He never
addresses the fact that he got ringorm from a furry convention
when she passed one to Katie. He never addressed the fact that
he sent Katie home on the day of her birthday. He never addressed
the fact that he uses a baby voice or sucked his thumb. He never
addressed the fact that he made weird uh comparisons to underage
Game of Thrones characters. Uh he never addressed the fact that
he was completely emotionally oblivious. He never addressed the
fact that he might be or that Destiny used a buck plug when they
met up. He never addressed the fact that ghost uh he ghost writes
all of his videos on YouTube. Never addressed his weird rockstar
fantasy. He never addressed his living conditions or hygiene
such as the Zen volcano. He never addressed the fact that he
went to church and got kicked out by the pastor for looking like
a slob. He never addressed the fact that he has a self harm history.
He never addressed the fact that he would not use lube for no
reason other than to He never addressed the fact that he would
not buy a return flight for the girls that he flies out. He would
not address the fact that he threatened Sacramento. >> Yeah,
none of these. Oh, well, hold on. Maybe this last >> about
the Kiwi Farms. And >> he threat for the girls that he
flies out. He would not address the fact that he threatened Sacramento
about the Kiwi
>> Dude, he's legitimately totally out of breath. But um
threatened Sacramento about the Kiwi Farm. What was that one?
I don't even know what that allegation is. A lot of the rest
of these are again just things that like people go, "Eh, I don't
really care." Almost all of the rest of them are just things
where people don't give a [__]
right? Or they're literally things where people just go, "Oh,
he's so awesome." Uh Tom wouldn't pay to send these women back.
Tom wouldn't Tom would like uh lie to these women to [__]
him. People just go, "Oh, based. Oh, cool. Oh, he's so cool."
Like he he could just farm incels all he wants with like this.
and he never addressed the fact that he the dog girl. Okay.
In fact, this is one of the only things that Sacramento provided
any evidence for. There are pictures of her in the same room
uh that she is taking photographs of herself in. And finally,
the one thing that Turkey Tom never ever ever addresses is that
she said that his live-in roommate, who had, for whatever reason,
his own money, his own wife, his own child, also uh did nitrous
oxide before going to the hospital and making a GoFundMe for
$350,000,
which he cr claimed was from an accident and not from a vitamin
deficiency from using drugs. And this is the biggest sticking
point. He never ever addressed why Brandon, his roommate, doxed
her, and that is that she claimed that he scammed $350,000
uh for a drug addiction.
here's [laughter] the here is
uh is it hold on.
Uh, is it a scam if he's like literally going through all of
this like health like uh organ failure and
is it a scam? Does he have to say I did whippets and you shouldn't
defend you shouldn't like fund me? Is that a scam?
I actually don't know if people feel that way. >> My final
thoughts >> cuz I don't think anybody's No, nobody's suggesting
that he's not actually sick. People are suggesting that
is he actually dying? What organs does he need? Let's see.
the initial diagnosis was acute systolic heart failure, kipsoquid
sepsis or possibly tuberculosis. The good news is that they no
longer think I have tuberculosis. The bad news is my heart is
still failing. My lungs, liver, and kidneys are still all still
very long recovery and I will not be able to provide for my family
for at least a few months, for at least several months if things
go well. A cardiology specialist informed me that I may be on
bed rest anywhere from 2 to four months as I recover from this
very scary life-threatening illness. I will need help with things
like my mortgage, utilities, baby supplies, and the over 100,000
in medical debt I have racked up while dealing with this nightmare.
I also will likely need to be on heart medication the rest of
my life. I've never asked for help before, but my heart is currently
only working at 15 to 20%. So, if anyone out there cares, please
consider donating to my GoFundMe to help me provide until I'm
able to work again.
So he said it at 75K he accepted 341K.
Yeah. I just don't know.
I I feel like if he got this from Whippets,
I don't know if I feel like he needs to disclose that or not,
especially if it's not a sure thing. So
>> um if this woman, if Rohan
had not lied about a couple things that were foundational to
their relationship that Turkey Tom could demonstra uh this is
pretty if he just doesn't have although we don't know that he
doesn't have health insurance. He says he's got all the medical
debt. You guys are saying he didn't have insurance.
If they found out he was using drugs or if they found drugs in
his system, I do think that could easily invalidate his coverage
for this for this illness. No, depending on what they figure
out point a finger at and say she's lying about this. Um, you
would have the hottest [__] goss for days. But she
ignored me. I sent her an email. The first thing that I said
to her when she sent me an email asking for an invite was, "Tell
the truth and back up everything that you say with evidence if
you can." And she ignored me. And as a result, um, she is going
to be, uh, really seriously
dealing with consequences as a result of this.
Um,
what I mean, I guess she got doxed by
By the way, there is one good point in this entire video, and
I'm not sure if Null just said it. Am I? I definitely heard it
the first time. I didn't just hear it now, but I wasn't. I was
kind of, you know, in the moment paying attention to chat and
stuff. There's one good point in this entire video and it's that
I think Brandon Buckingham docks this woman not be because she
talked about him and his GoFundMe being based on hints. I think
he was extremely furious at her directly and decided to try to
[__] with her life directly.
I think that's the one thing I can agree with that Brandon Buckingham
did this not because oh I just she with my roommate. No, I think
she with you with your life in some way and that's what you're
actually angry at and that's why you doxed her.
>> The other issue
>> also whippets are just duster, right?
Uh, is Kayla just like way stronger spiritually than Brandon
Buckingham? Caleb been on Duster? Caleb been huffing Duster for
like years now? No downside.
Nitrous. Oh, no. Nitrous is different. Never mind. Never mind.
Never mind. It's not the same. They're different. >> Is
that uh this will come up again. You can be really [__]
mad at me all you want, but this is going to happen again. It's
going to happen in a year or two because um
dude dude it's so funny just thinking of cousins again nitrous
don't help me just put me in a trance
he's going to do the exact same [__] thing that he
did before and he's going to get into trouble with it again because
his idol is apparently Destiny and she sent me a message and
I had been ignoring her but she sent me a message that I was
interested in. So I looked up into it um and
I'm not watching that Tom McDonald video. I'm so sorry. >> During
a brief conversation
and I said, "Have you ever seen this video?" And it's the video
of It's Mel Time where Destiny's wife Molina gets up and dances
with a black man behind
him while he looks like he's in agony.
And the uh
phrase it's Mel time has become a sticking point uh to refer
to Destiny as a
she told me in response to this, "Oh, that makes sense. He has
a playlist on Spotify called It's Kai Time filled with sappy
emo breakup songs.
Dude, and
[laughter] that was really funny. I laughed at that. And it's
just like if you had just not lied about the really obvious to
make yourself look more like a victim, that would be really really
funny. And people would find that really really I wish we could
find that playlist. I want to I want to find that play. Dude,
that playlist would be sick.
Tom, I will officially be Turkey Tom's
like advocate online forever more
if he publishes that playlist. Okay, Ralph did say this was true.
Okay, I need the playlist though. I don't need I don't need just
confirmation of the playlist existence. Okay, I need the playlist
I need the playlist. >> Funny. And it would be something
that people would bring up about Turkey for years to come that
it's Kai time because she them. Um, but she tried to make it
about herself and and tried to lie to make herself look more
like a victim. So there will be no long-term consequences
uh for this. Uh but as I said, it will happen again cuz if you're
stacking up bodies 15 high in a year, uh eventually
uh let's say that he has 15 partners and two of them came out
and called him like a weird goon clown.
Um, and he's doing this once a month, every month. Uh, you're
going to hit another [__] landmine, buddy. It's going
to be about seven months before you pick off another girl. It's
gonna I think Tom had basically decided that this wasn't going
to be how he lived anymore, right?
And I I can believe it for Tom that he basically was like up
and he kind of moved on. If Tom can give up like streaming and
like a lot of attention and just do his main stream or his main
channel videos and not really need to appear on right, I do believe
he's he has the capacity for change. If somebody's like 35 saying
they're going to change everything up, I don't believe them.
If somebody's like 20 saying they're going to change things up
and they have shown some capacity for change, I'm more inclined
to believe that. Um, you guys could say that's optimistic or
whatever. I do think Tom's young enough to like move on to other
I do think he's got the restraint. I do think he could do it.
Um, no, I just think he's got the willpower to do it. We'll see.
>> I want to talk. >> I don't think he'll necessarily
have like, unless he solves some of the communication issues,
I don't think he'll necessarily have like great relationships,
but I do think it won't be like the, you know, rolling through
bad relationship to bad relationship to bad relationship, all
short-term sh you uh it's going to be about a year before you
pick off two of them that might meet each other. >> So,
here's my um here's my point, okay?
Uh I don't want to litigate the minutia of the claims because
it's just an aside at this point. Like these are the things that
she said that he didn't bother to address and he didn't bother
to address them because he doesn't have to. He's able to prove
that one of the most important things about her story was a lie,
that she didn't know him before matching him on Tinder. So therefore,
everything else is also a lie.
Uh, however, he can expect that certain things that were said
are going to >> has learned to stop hitting and choking
girls without discussing it with them
Yeah, if
I mean again
I Katie and this other girl met him pretty far apart and I wonder
it's really hard for me to take almost any part of the Rowan
stuff seriously the the Sacramento stuff seriously because of
the lies.
I do wonder how much he discussed it with her beforehand
like if at all in person. I do wonder if they talk right
like there is a there's a way you could progress to that kind
of stuff that makes sense
and
based on how she was talking about it. I don't know that he did
anything that she was like not okay
Yeah, there were texts of it, Missy Elliot. The texts were, "Oh,
I didn't know I'd like stuff like that." Right. But it's not
anything to do with like I didn't I didn't expect you to do that.
I I didn't like I wasn't okay with that. It was nothing like
that. And so there are ways you could you could escalate to stuff
like that that don't violate consensual bounds that you can like
establish consent. I'm convinced he didn't do
like I I do believe that that conversation goes differently if
Tom had just slapped this girl in the face before they'd escalated
to like that stage of in some way, right?
Like I don't I don't believe I don't believe the text looked
that way. I don't believe the anything looks that way.
If he just slapped this girl in the face with like no other conversation
at all.
I don't I don't believe that particularly
now that you have the text and she's talking about it. Right.
>> The idea that the Kiwi Farms makes is really funny.
>> Um and that's going to get brought up regardless of
if people think it's true or not. It's a matter of if they like
you or not. That depends on if uh they >> by the way if
she had done consentually he'd done something without asking
her. Even if she said something like well I didn't think expect
to be into that but I I was surprised that I liked it. If she
said something like that I would have condemnation for that.
Right. But I'm saying
um didn't give the impression that they talked a lot about it.
Well not about the specific thing. Yeah. Not about the very specific
thing that she's referring to. Sure. But it doesn't mean they
didn't talk about stuff in that direction. It just means probably
the thing he did was not something they
Yeah. It's true.
is that I like Turkey Tom and
um when I talk to him I try to give him like actually good advice
and I try to >> Dude, a lot of a lot of people in Null's
chat are just him right now. Jesus
James. encourage him to everything you could possibly want. Just
don't [__] it up. And uh he wants to like idolize
Destiny who's a complete [__] whose life is like
always hanging by a thread. He's being sued for revenge.
He lost the co-host to his podcast. He can't ever like So true.
Philip Oliver holds. So true. Treated his texting like he's being
exposed already. He treats smack and up the same. Definitely
talk and confirm first, [laughter] dude. Pretend Tom is gonna
have to escalate from pretending all of his texts are already
leaked to pretending all of his tapes are already leaked. Okay?
He's got to escalate the the paranoia further. All right?
Explicit verbal consent for every single act you do. Okay? [snorts]
Go up in politics like Hassan [__] because he's always
going to be that revenge goon clown. It's like why the would
you idolize that?
And
it me off that the most prominent people who have ever had a
direct association with the Kiwi Farms
are like deranged. Do you know what the number by the way? I
just as much as he would have talked about Destiny before.
I can't see how you'd say he idol like she had some commentary
on it, right? the the Sacramento person. But you just think that
if that were the case for Tom that he would
like not have just basically said, "Oh, Destiny sucks." and never
covered it again. You know what I mean?
You know what I'm saying? Like if he actually idolize the guy,
you think he'd just be back in there like sort of lapping up
the same cope as a lot of other people were doing? It just it
doesn't really track with what I expect about Tom,
right? or what I would expect from somebody who like idolized
Destiny like they say think Tom was hurt. Sure. Might have been
hurt. >> Three the top three people who have definitely
had Kiwi Farms accounts are like in terms of popularity Stury
Tom
Pippa Pipkins
and Shondo.
Two of which are O
get the deep boom on that one.
Uh, Pippa
pro. I don't know if Pipa does the
baiting stuff.
It's like she's a VTuber. I don't know if she does baiting necessarily.
I I have not watched the content. I know she's like the racist
VTuber. The Shondo person is the baby person, right? The Shondo
person is the person from the Britney Venty video. That baby
like pacifier in the mouth. That's who Shondo is, right? Or just
outright pedalling YouTubers
to So, I want to I want to round this out
um with some advice. First of all, I have consulted the Supreme
Council of Women. Okay? Uh I understand that it's scary being
a young person today trying to find a partner, trying to find
a a boyfriend, girlfriend. So, the Supreme Council of Soviets
Women Edition on the Kiwi Farms has given me the following advice
to women chat. This guy's got some crazy voice cracks going on,
too. Not a good look, man. Um, first,
do not trauma dump about your mental illnesses right away [laughter]
because you are only going to attract predators and scare off
normal men. And four, don't seek validation from casual with
men. That is what the women uh have relayed to me uh for advice
for women. >> It's just it's just weird cuz it's like >> um
advice for men. uh stop watching 100% of his issues would go
away if he stopped death gripping. Like I um
I just don't know why.
Like sure it seems like Tom's got some issues around.
I agree.
I don't know why I don't know why null's
is null the guy is null that guy who's gonna he's got the advice
he's at the end of it >> I don't know what evidence I have
of this that that null's got some like successful relationships
under his belt >> stop just not you're [__]
yourself up
>> um stop being a man [__] uh because you're
you're going to seriously damage your your understanding of relationships
yourself based off how any bodies you can lay or whatever. Cuz
if you're not happy with who you are, you're not going to be
happy after having sex with 30 random prostitutes from the internet.
Um, and everyone who wants to cope that I don't know what I'm
talking about cope. I don't give a [__] >> The
issue, by the way, I'm certain. >> Well, I don't think
he's not demonstrating that he's had a lot of He's like giving
a bunch of advice and Okay, anyone who wants to go vote that
I don't know what I'm Okay, maybe he maybe he's had a lot of
relationships. I don't know.
I
like I get it.
It's not like I'm advocating to watch like a It's just like I
don't think
>> I don't know, man. >> I just don't I don't think
it's like that big a deal to be honest with you. >> I tried
to to press her for an actual answer and I couldn't get a straight
one. So, I'm just going to give you my theory. I think that the
reason she's actually pissed off that this Rowan woman is like,
"Okay, I have to like murder this man. I have to try and ruin
his life with fake accusations." I think the reason >> Yeah.
No, no, I'm good.
I called him a virgin in his chat and this was his response.
Uh, a lot of people in the chat seem to be
calling
basically calling him out, saying he's coping,
coping, seething.
Hey, what can you do, man? Rough rough week for Josh. >> Was
uh the cheat with Ellie. >> Uh, if you're going to be totally
in possession of a woman, you have to be exclusive. If you are
trying to completely own somebody as like a slave, you have to
[snorts] be uh exclusive because if you're not, then they're
giving up literally everything in exchange for nothing. And that
will cause a uh normal person to break and it will cause an insane
person to go completely and try to ruin your life. Um so don't
do that. [laughter]
I'll just say what we all want. Okay. Can we get a Dickers null
podcast at some point in the near future just on like BDSM?
I need a Dickers null podcast, preferably in person where they
could discuss BDSM techniques. I think this is what we all want,
what we all need.
please, just these two together in a room.
[laughter]
And that's it. That's all I have to say. In case you're wondering,
you're twice as likely to be raped by a gay man than you are
to be falsely accused. You only said that because Dickers rated
Nick. I'm fine with Dickers rating Nick.
I I don't mind if by the way that works better for everybody.
If Dickers has a relationship with Nick like the Aiden Nick bridge
is not going to exist for very much longer. Okay.
So if it would be better for all of us involved. Okay. >> So
So Nick's not, you know, totally out of reach >> of
[snorts] um is extraordinarily incredibly
immensely uh bad thing that Rowan did. And I assume that there's
going to be consequences for it based off what I've seen. Uh
Ferman for two says, "Do you think
>> um did what did what Sacramento or Rowan did, does that
rise to defamation?"
I'm trying to think of like what you could say she knowingly
lied about.
Maybe
maybe it could rise to de defamation.
I'm trying to think of if it could
because I it seems pretty obvious that null's hinting that
that she's getting sued, right?
I think I didn't get to see the super chats. Okay. Do you think
if another allegation interview took place in the future, you'd
get some you'd voice some skepticism or do you feel like it's
best to stick to just letting the accusers talk? He's probably
got to say just letting the accusers talk. other allegation interview
took place in the future. You'd voice the same skepticism or
you think it's best just to stick to letting accusers talk. I
mean the thing is I had no reason to
you have reason to doubt what she said.
I'm trying to think of like what I thought was it was basically
like well there's not really a lot of evidence here.
I'm trying to think of like what parts I personally felt was
like not reliable here.
Um, I mean, most of the criminal allegations, right, the the
record of this, you're basically you're making an allegation
with no evidence, right? You got nothing and you're explicitly
saying you have nothing.
So, I don't know. I don't know in that one.
Trying to think like what she explicitly lied about were things
like how did did she know who Turkey Tom was? And I do think
there was suspicious stuff there, right? I really do think there
was I was very suspicious of that. I didn't believe that at all.
I thought for sure you know who Turkey Tom is. I said as much
ended up being vindicated on that one. Sure. Allegations are
just things that can't be proven. And then a lot of the innuendo,
it's like I believe this more or less. I I like believe this.
It seems to make some kind of sense,
but it doesn't really matter cuz you can't really hold it against
him. Like the fact that this guy might have gone on a trip to
Maine or Massachusetts with her, I forget, and his didn't work.
It's like, okay, I believe that.
And I think that's even substantiated by some of the further
DMs that Tom doesn't read out. I think Tom actually leaked the
substantiation for this. I don't think I pointed it out, but
I think at some point she after they get back from that trip,
she says like when you're coming um is your working yet or something
like that. She asked that him that question. So I'd say there's
some substantiation behind that one. But again, that's just like
that's purely innuendo that just makes fun of him. It's not even
something that like
I don't know. It's not it's not like tangible in any way. seemed
like the accusations got more detailed than extreme during the
interview, the live interview. Some of them I
might have just been the descriptions like that they she would
have given those descriptions if asked, but she wasn't asked
the right questions.
There's a good bit of too good to be true stuff with no proof.
Well, I'd say the part where it was like Kiwi Farms that made
it so he couldn't get hard. I think that's probably goofy. That's
that seemed like too much. Yeah. >> Spoke. If you listen
to the Logan Day interview, the Logan Day interview was much
more hostile because Lo Oh my god, he went to Maine and his didn't
work and you guys locked onto it. What?
I'm just I'm just explaining something that happened. I literally
said it doesn't matter. It's just something they're using to
make fun of him. Like doesn't matter to me. >> Day was
uh just with a very obvious line of questioning was able to fall
apart. She did not handle well when when I asked her questions.
I couldn't get like what I did is I went through the timeline.
I stuck to a chronological timeline and I pressed her on certain
things uh to see if she was consistent with her story. That's
the only thing I could do. Um and she answered the questions.
And in fact, the line of questioning that I did was so thorough
that Turkey Tom used it repeatedly in his own video to defend
himself.
This is just This is cope. I don't know, man. It feels pretty
copey.
Uh, I it feels pretty copey, man.
What would we have done here? I do think there were reasons that
you could voice skepticism
that you could ask questions that would basically like explicitly
say, "So, you're saying you'd never seen a Turkey video. There's
no evidence you'd seen like like if we looked at your YouTube
history, right?
I I do think and now it's going to be it's rough for me to say
this now
like and now it's all in retrospect,
Yeah, I I just don't think um
Oh, hold on. I It's just It's easy to come up the stuff now because
we know what what has been proven false. >> So, I was poking
uh holes in a story that he could later use to help him refute
what she was saying, which is about all you can ask from an interviewer.
Um,
it's not my fault that she was able to hold a story together
to try and ruin him. Um, but I did my due diligence in proving
that she was in a relationship with him, had been at his house,
had pictures of her there like they both did.
I'm not sure what else I'm supposed to do. What am I supposed
to say? Like, you're lying. You're lying to me when when you
say when you're when you're on the verge of tears talking about
you're full of [__] lady. Like,
there's no purpose to that.
I
I think there's a lot of people who had no interest in believing
this story from the beginning on Kiwi Farms.
And I think Josh going to have a real hard time living down the
like
like basically the the feminist null here.
Ah, I think this I think this interview does a lot of reputational
damage to it with the people who, you know, inhabit his forum.
There's no there's no inkling that I have
um to say that and the times
and my credit again when she said certain things I said why don't
you go to the police why didn't you break it up then why did
you stay with this guy and there was a moment if you remember
where I asked that and she just said he had big muscles which
I just laugh text it's like okay what the [__] kind
of response is that
so um I still maintain I did the best absolute best [__]
job I could have I had no reason to doubt them And I asked questions
that were thorough enough and professional. >> This is
always a mistake, by the way, to go and
to if if you have if you something up and to never ever give
the audience some small concession at all. This is what Tom did,
by the way. Tom knew to do this cuz Tom's not a null is doing
this thing where he is doing like no concessions. Actually, actually,
when you think about it, I'm even better than you really thought,
right?
That is never a good idea on the internet if you up in any way.
It's just always a bad idea if you It's such a bad idea, man.
It is pirate software coded. It's stupid. Tom, oh, the age play
thing. Listen guys, sometimes I you know, girls call me daddy.
It is what it is. I know you guys are going to think I'm weird
for that. Which in and of itself is like, what's your biggest
weakness? I work too hard. It's like that kind of answer where
it's like not even really something that's embarrassing. You're
giving like a cope answer to make yourself seem better, right?
But he gave some kind of concession. And he was the one who was
in the right.
Josh is in the wrong. Can't even get can't get any concession.
>> Enough that turkey time could use them in his own defense.
So, I'm not sure why I'm expected by anybody to take any blame
for anything. It's not my fault that his ex wanted to accuse
him of uh her until she bled. It's not my fault. Um, you know,
you can blame her, you can blame him, but you can't blame me.
>> Okay.
I don't know about that one, man. I I
just feel like
And by the way, maybe he asked these questions in private, but
he should have asked them in the interview. They should have
been on the record, like things about asking for contemporaneous
messages and stuff. Okay. You got any other texts that back some
of the stuff up? get any other texts that back up even some of
this uh you said you said his didn't work. Do you have text backing
that up? Do you have evidence backing that up? Or is that just
like innuendo? Basically, anything where she was making some
kind of allegation or some kind of insinuation that was negative
about him, you could have easily said, "Do you have more evidence
backing this up? Do you have more evidence backing this up? Do
you have more evidence backing this up?" And it felt like that
wasn't happening anywhere near as much. Okay.
And then I do think you probably have to go without asking for
a picture or a size rating on his I think that ends up being
goofy as hell, man. You ask you asking for the size of the it
really didn't It's not a good look, bro. It's not a good look,
bro. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. It's just not a good look, man. It's
some goofy, man.